[Musik]
ich habe zwei Stunden lang gezittert
ja vor Kälte oder wegen der Nerven
verstehen Sie
hier war die Küche
zweimal eine Dreizimmerwohnung
ich bin während Monaten in Ukraine
unterwegs bei Menschen die im russischen
Angriffskrieg alles verloren haben
haben wir gesehen wie die Männer die
Leute ausgegraben haben und sie hier auf
den Vorplatz legten
sondern in Stücken knochenhände Füße
[Musik]
ein Jahr Krieg kein Tag ohne Luftalarm
kein Tag ohne russischen Beschuss auf
die Ukraine offiziell bestätigt sind
über 9000 getötete Zivilisten darunter
495 Kinder
wie viele Zivilisten die russische Armee
in Ukraine genau getötet hat weiß
niemand
[Musik]
Zerstörung ist nach einem Jahr Krieg in
vielen Städten der Ukraine anzutreffen
auch Häuser wie dieses einst ein
Wohnhaus jetzt eine Ruine auf dieses
Haus und der piramisgeilstraße 2 stoße
ich ein halbes Jahr nach Kriegsbeginn im
September 2022 in isum die Stadt isum
liegt in der Ostukraine isum stand
während Monaten unter Beschuss und
gehört zu den am stärksten vom Krieg
zerstörten Städten des Landes
[Musik]
in der Ostukraine ist die Front nicht
weit die Bedrohung ist hier immer noch
allgegenwärtig
es ist ein warmer Tag im Herbst als ich
diesem Haus zum ersten Mal begegne und
Sonnenschein nichts will zusammenpassen
ich beginne mit der Suche nach
Überlebenden die mir erzählen können was
hier vorgefallen ist
wir treffen einen Überlebenden der
jahrelang in diesem Haus gelebt hat
Michael jetzt sind jung
um 9 Uhr morgens sagte meine Enkelin zu
mir Opa bring mir einen Tee ich nehme
die Thermosflasche den Tee und gehe zu
Treppe meine Frau sagte noch zu mir
Micha ich komme mit ich sagte ihr zieh
dich an ich warte doch noch bevor sie
bei mir auf dem Flur ist gibt es diese
Explosion
wie lange ich ohne Bewusstsein war weiß
ich nicht
als ich zu mir kam da verstand ich dass
ich alleine war ich rief Natascha
nirgendwo waren Geräusche zu hören so
begann mich nach Hilfe zu rufen
er hat als einzige seine Familie den
Angriff vor Ort überlebt insgesamt
starben sechs Mitglieder seine Familie
seine Frau seine Tochter sein
Schwiegersohn und drei seine Enkelkinder
[Musik]
ich war dort hier bei diesem Eingang
dort schlage ich weiter unten
alle anderen Leute waren hier
in diesem Bereich
das wurden Leute hier gefunden
und hier die Mehrheit der Verstorbenen
wurde hier gefunden
dieses Video wurde Anfang März
aufgenommen nur wenige Tage bevor die
russische Armee das Haus zerstörte die
Frau die das Video gemacht hat ist bei
der Explosion getötet worden
die Menschen suchten im kellerschutz und
wurden von Trümmern begraben wie viele
getötet wurden ist unklar offiziell
bestätigt sind 44 tote Augen sollten der
Ausgrabung sprechen von 54 Opfern
die Bewohner des Hauses hatten einen
gemeinsamen Chat die letzten Nachrichten
stammen von Anfang mehr nur hier hat ein
Nachbar der auch getötet worden ist noch
geschrieben im Falle eines Beschusses
schalten Sie alle das Gas aus es heißt
Panzer würden in unsere Richtung fahren
nicht unsere Panzer
damals durfte man das Licht nicht mehr
anschalten damit um Himmels Willen
nichts passieren würde
alle Vorsichtsmaßnahmen halfen nichts am
9 März kurz nach 9 Uhr sollte sich das
Leben der Bewohner des Hauses für immer
verändern
die Familie von Irina zog unmittelbar
nach Bau des Hauses in den 1980er Jahren
im Haus an der Bürgermeister der Straße
des ersten Mais ein Irina war damals
acht Jahre alt
ich kann mich noch erinnern wie das Haus
gebaut wurde mama Papa gehörten zu den
Leuten die das Haus gebaut haben
so viele Jahre haben wir dort gelebt
die Familie hat überlebt weil sie wenige
Tage vor der Explosion weggefahren ist
wir sind zwischen dem vierten und
fünften März weggefahren in Ischium gab
es zu diesem Zeitpunkt bereits kein
fließendes Wasser und keinen Strom mehr
meine Mutter ist gehbehindert sie fragte
mich wohin sollen wir ich sagte ihr lass
uns zu Großmutter auf das Dorf fahren
dort können wir auf dem Holzherd Wasser
kochen
[Musik]
ein erstes Mal nach isum zurückgekehrt
ist Serena erst einen Monat nach dem Tod
ihrer Nachbarn und Freunde wir fahren
mit ihr zurück in die Stadt
jede Rückkehr ist eine Rückkehr in eine
verlorene Vergangenheit voller
Erinnerungen
[Musik]
eine Freundin hat mich noch angerufen
kommen in den Keller runter sie bot mir
an mit dem Kinderwagen meiner Tochter zu
helfen aber ich sag dir nein in den
Keller komme ich nicht
ich ging fast nie in den Keller ich
hatte immer Angst dort hinab zu steigen
ich hatte Angst das Haus könnte über mir
zusammenbrechen
es gibt nur wenige Waffen die an
fünfstöckiges Haus zum Einsturz bringen
können
150.000 Häuser sind laut Schätzungen der
ukrainischen Behörden von der russischen
Armee im Krieg bisher zerstört worden
beim Haus an der piramiskai gehen die
ukrainischen Behörden davon aus dass
Russlands Armee eine Fliegerbombe über
dem Haus abgeworfen hat
[Musik]
dabei soll es sich um eine Farb 500
Fliegerbombe gehandelt haben hier Bilder
vom russischen Verteidigungsministerium
diese Fliegerbomben wurden von der
russischen Armee bereits in der
Vergangenheit in anderen Kriegen wie
hier in Syrien eingesetzt
auch zivile Infrastrukturen der Ukraine
hat die russische Armee nachweislich mit
dieser Fliegerbombe angegriffen hier zum
Beispiel die Stadt rakif solche Bomben
gegen zivile Ziele einzusetzen ist ein
Kriegsverbrechen rarif ist 120 km
Luftlinie von ISO entfernt
auch auf isum sollen mindestens zwei
Farb 500 Fliegerbomben abgeworfen worden
sein
ich habe kein Flugzeug gehört vielleicht
lag es daran dass ich im Keller war an
den Tagen zuvor habe ich Explosionen
gehört aber am 9 März da kann ich mich
nicht daran erinnern
die Erinnerung von Michael sind
verschwommen teilweise bruchstückhaft es
scheint heute überzeugt davon dass es
sich selbst aus den Trümmern befreit hat
auch wenn andere dieser Erinnerung
widersprechen
Michael ist verabredet mit jedem
Nachbarn den nach der Explosion unter
den Trümmern gefunden hat
hallo Sascha hallo wie geht es dir gut
rasier dich mal nein werde ich nicht
hier lag Michelle
aus den Trümmern zu befreien wir haben
Ziegelsteine weggeräumt
sie haben zu zwei Ziegelsteine
weggeräumt und dann vielen Trümmer von
oben runter du bist mit dem anderen
weggegangen in dein Häuschen nebenan
wir haben Ziegelsteine weggeräumt und du
hast geschrieben wir sollen deine
Familie befreien
Michael fühlt sich allein gelassen und
Alexandra ist verletzt dass ihm der
Nachbar unterstellt ihn zurückgelassen
zu haben
in einem Punkt sind sie sich einig die
Verschütteten aus dem Keller zu befreien
war zu diesem Zeitpunkt unmöglich
zu schwer wurden die Betonplatten unter
welchen die Menschen begraben waren
es sollte noch mehr als ein Monat
vergehen bis die Toten aus dem Keller
geborgen werden konnten
dazwischen seit versuchten die
Überlebenden aus ihren Wohnung zu retten
was zu retten war
Alexander nimmt uns mit in die Ruine
seiner Wohnung
dazu muss er durch die zerstörte Wohnung
eines Nachbarn der beim Angriff getötet
wurde alexander ist das unangenehm
prestig verzeihen Sie bitte
und diese Figur aus Thailand ist am
Leben
[Musik]
am 8 März war ich in der Wohnung habe
hier noch einen Kaffee getrunken mich
aufs Sofa gelegt und eine Sendung auf
Youtube angesehen
abends
gegangen als hätte ich es gespürt dass
ich raus muss
unten liegen
Ende des Jahres 2,4 Millionen Ukraine
und Ukraine und zerstörten oder schwer
beschädigten Wohnungen
[Musik]
Alexander bringt die noch erhaltene
Figur seine Frau titana
bei uns was einem gehört ist einem teuer
sie klammern sich an die wenigen
Überbleibsel ihres einstigen Lebens
wir sind jetzt ohne bleibe aber das
schlimmste ist dass es unsere lieben
Nachbarn nicht mehr gibt wir lebten
einst vor uns hin Nachbarn sind Nachbarn
seit sie tot sind fühlen wir uns wie
weisen
Alexander und Tiziana Lieben heute in
ihrem Wochenendhäuschen gleich neben dem
zerstörten Wohnhaus zusammen mit ihrem
Hund
als die Flugzeuge geflogen hatte er
Angst auch wir nahmen Beruhigungsmittel
er ist nicht erzogen weil er im
Luftschutzkeller während des Krieges
groß wurde
auch in der Nähe ihres
wochenendhäuschens haben Raketen
eingeschlagen sie haben kein Dach und
heizen mit einem alten Holzofen
nachdem die Fliegerbombe eingeschlagen
hat fanden mehrere Nachbarn die gerettet
werden konnten hier Unterschlupf
wir haben hier überall Matratzen
hingelegt und uns zugedeckt mit allen
möglichen wir haben versucht zu heizen
es war schließlich sehr kalt aber
irgendetwas mit dem Ofen stimmte nicht
den vergangenen Monaten lebten sie hier
zu zweit weiter unter schwierigsten
Bedingungen
ich bin ja ein Mann aber wenn ich mit
dem Hund rausging habe ich jedes Mal
geweint
jetzt bin ich abgehärtet aber es war
schwer
[Musik]
am aller schwersten war es als sie
begonnen haben die Leute zu bergen
nur das klappt
sie schauen von ihrer vorübergehenden
bleibe jeden Tag auf die Ruinen ihrer
alten Wohnung und an ihnen Ort an dem
ihre Nachbarn im Keller starb
komm doch als die Leute anonym unter
einer Nummer begraben wurden ließen die
Russen niemanden zu den Gräbern auch
Angehörige nicht
getöteten gleich hinter den
Eingangstoren zur Stadt
ich bin an diesem Ort wenige Tage nach
der Befreiung der Stadt durch die
ukrainische Armee
[Musik]
waren knapp sechs Monaten hatte die
russische Armee die Stadt besetzt
gehalten während der Besatzung von Ende
März bis Mitte September starben
hunderte Menschen in isum
mehrere folterkiller wurden nach der
Befreiung gefunden darüber will vor Ort
niemand sprechen die Menschen hier
befürchten die russische Armee könnte
jederzeit zurückkommen
ist gezeichnet von Krieg die Straßen
sind voller Militärtechnik welche die
russische Armee beim Rückzug
zurückgelassen hat
erstmals nach Ende der Besatzung ist
doch das Massengrab zugänglich
alle Zivilisten die während der
Besatzung gestorben sind wurden hier
vergraben
in 445 Gräbern auf fast alle getöteten
des Hauses an der perver Meister sind
hier beerdigt die Nachbarn und Freunde
von Irina Alexander und Michael
ich bin während der extremierung vor Ort
und kämpfe mit Übelkeit Geruch und
Anblick der verwesenden Leichen nur
schwer auszuhalten
und die Todesursache und die Identität
feststellen zu können werden die Toten
examiniert
bislang wurden den Ukraine mehr als
1.000 Zivilisten und Soldaten aus Massen
10.000 Untersuchungen haben die
ukrainischen Behörden wegen mutmaßlicher
russischer Kriegsverbrechen aufgenommen
Leichen werden in die nächstgelegene
größere Stadt gefahren
bis heute dauern diese Untersuchungen
der Behörden an
[Musik]
während der Besatzung hat er geholfen
die Menschen zu vergraben der 30-Jährige
ich hatte nach dem Begräbnissen einen
Bandscheibenvorfall der sich noch
verschlimmert hat es war schmerzhaft
wir mussten die Leichen zu zweit zu
dritt oder zu viertragen es gab sehr
unterschiedliche Leute teilweise waren
die sehr schwer alle die sich an die
Begräbnissen beteiligt hatten trugen
gesundheitliche Schäden davon
er nimmt uns mit
dem Haus an der Bürgermeister ihr Sohn
und seine Familie sind beim Angriff
getötet worden
am Stadtrand begleiten
auch ihre Familie hat Pavlo begraben er
hat während der Besatzung erlebt wie
überall in der Stadt tote lagen
wir gingen durch die Stadt waren
unterwegs in den Luftschutzkeller in
jedem Innenhof standen damals Kreuze von
Menschen die direkt dort begraben worden
waren die einen waren eines natürlichen
Todes gestorben die anderen unter
Beschuss einige hielten es schlicht
nicht mehr aus und haben Suizid begangen
um die getöteten Zivilisten außerhalb
der Stadt zu begraben
längst nicht alle wollten sich darum
kümmern ich habe nach dem Prinzip
gehandelt wer wenn nicht wir
abzuraten war keine Option der Sommer
stand vor der Tür und es war nicht klar
wo das alles noch enden würde
zwischen April hierher und Zivilisten zu
beerdigen
ohne ihn hätte sich Galina nicht hierher
getraut
ihre Verwandten hatte sie damals bereits
bei der Bergung aus dem Keller Versuch
zu identifizieren
es waren schon zwei Monate vergangen bis
Sie ausgegraben wurden der Gestank war
grauenhaft es war nicht möglich sie zu
identifizieren sie waren nicht zu
erkennen die Kleider die Gesichter die
Haare waren verbrannt
wo sind unsere Kreuze
[Musik]
so viele wurden hier beerdigt
ich habe allen auch Blumen gekauft
[Musik]
danke dir
meinen Sohn habe ich erkannt er war der
einzige mit einem Gesicht
nur bei ihm war das Gesicht erhalten als
sie ihn geborgen haben zeigte sich dass
sein Kopf unter Rohren begraben lag die
Rohre waren über seinem Kopf in Stücke
geborsten ihn zu erkennen war leichter
denn er war mit einem Meter 90 sehr groß
und 105 Kilogramm schwer
Galina konnte ihre Schwiegertochter und
die älteste Enkeltochter nach der
Bergung aus dem Keller nicht
identifizieren sie wartete Aushebung des
Massengrabes auf die Ergebnisse der
DNA-Analysen
die leitende am mittleren hat mir gesagt
dass sie sich bei mir melden wird sobald
die Ergebnisse der DNA-Analysen
vorliegen wenn die da sind werde ich
meine Angehörigen abholen und selbst
beerdigen ein Familiengrab wird uns
nicht gestattet aber Einzelgräber ich
möchte sie alle beerdigen
das Massengrab in Issum ist eines von
insgesamt 21 bekannten massengräbernen
Ukraine alle entstandenen Gebieten die
vorübergehend von den Russen besetzt
waren
die Angehörigen fast ein Jahr nach ihrem
Tod zu beerdigen das wünschen sich auch
jene die fern der Heimat is im Leben
es ist so ein schwerer Gefühlszustand
wenn Du selbst auf dem Friedhof nicht
weinen kannst weil du schon so viel
durch litten hast keine Tränen mehr hast
da keine Kraft für gar nichts mehr
bleibt um überhaupt noch Emotionen zu
spüren
ich treffe die 20-Jährige alone in Polen
sie lebt seit eineinhalb Jahren hier
alone ist im Haus an der Bürgermeister
in isum im dritten Stock aufgewachsen
hier hat sie mit ihren Eltern gelebt bis
sie volljährig wurde im Keller des
Hauses starben ihre Eltern und ihre
Großmutter
Aljona kann ich nach easium fahren weil
sie sonst ihren Aufenthaltsstatus in
Polen verlieren würde auf diesem
Friedhof knapp 300 Kilometer westlich
der Hauptstadt Warschau hat sie einen
Ort gefunden wo sie sich mit ihren
Eltern verbunden fühlt übrigens war
schon
ich habe Fotos meiner Eltern mitgebracht
damit ich sie vor mir sehe damit ich
mich von ihnen verabschieden kann ich
bin mit 20 Jahren voll weise geworden
ich habe keine Mutter keinen Vater ich
habe keine Unterstützung
auf dem Friedhof hat der lokale
Bürgermeister an Gedenkstein für die
Kriegsopfer in der Ukraine errichten
lassen
der Stein steht auf Steinen und ist
umgeben von Lehre
für mich ist das wie ein Symbol dessen
was jetzt vor sich geht in Issum
rundherum wächst noch etwas dort wo man
den Stein hingestellt hat ist einfach
nichts
[Musik]
es gibt nichts was alone die eigenen
Eltern wieder zurückbringen könnte mir
bleibt in dieser Situation als
journalistino etwas Menschen wie alona
zuzuhören und ihnen eine Stimme zu geben
[Musik]
ich kann nicht sagen dass unser Leben
normal weitergeht nein alles hat sich
verändert ich fühle mich nicht so als ob
ich 20 wäre ich möchte nicht ausgehen so
wie andere weil mir meine Familie
genommen wurde du wirst mit einem Schlag
um 30 Jahre älter
[Musik]
ein wenig Trost findet Aljona bei Ihrer
Katze
auf dem Tod ihrer Eltern was für alone
ist sehr schwer in ihrem Leben wieder
Tritt zu fassen
ich habe mir die Haare geschnitten und
gefärbt weil ich meiner Mutter immer
ähnlicher sehe
es ist schwer in den Spiegel zu sehen
und meine Mutter darin wieder zu
erkennen
ich kann nicht mit ihr sprechen sie
nicht umarmen ihr nichts erzählen
habe fällt mir das Atmen leichter
es ist nicht mehr die Stadt an welche
ich mich erinnere ich möchte dorthin
zurückkehren aber dies mit eigenen Augen
zu sehen ist beängstigend
früher war es eine sehr schöne Stadt mit
vielen jungen Menschen viele sind
weggefahren aber immer zurückgekehrt es
gab immer Leben in der Stadt aber jetzt
gibt es das nicht und wird es auch nicht
mehr geben
[Gelächter]
vom Leben an der Bier war Meister sind
in Bewohnern nur Erinnerungen und
Fotografien geblieben
[Musik]
unsere Wohnung war dort oben wo das
Linoleum runterhängt
hier liegen noch die Bücher meines
Sohnes die aus der Wohnung
runtergefallen sind
diese Schulhefte aus der fünften Klasse
André Kovalenko
in ihrer Wohnung ist mehr erhalten
geblieben als in anderen Wohnungen
für sie ein schwacher Trost
doch was wir mitnehmen konnten haben wir
mitgenommen alles können wir sowieso
nicht mitnehmen wir leben ja in einer
fremden Wohnung
offiziell sind 4,8 Millionen
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine innerhalb des
Landes vom Krieg vertrieben worden
über die Landesgrenzen hinaus sind vier
Millionen Menschen geflüchtet
für die Menschen die ich in isum
kennengelernt habe hat der Krieg alles
verändert Pablo möchte weg zumindest für
eine Weile er packt seine Sachen
noch immer rufen Leute an und fragen
nach Hilfe um jemanden zu finden viele
Menschen sind verschollen
sobald du dich ein wenig erholen
konntest ruft wieder jemand an und alles
kommt hoch
ich kann nicht sagen dass ich schwer
psychisch gelitten habe aber ich möchte
ohne solche Ausbrüche Leben ich möchte
Ruhe und unter einem friedlichen Himmel
weiterleben können
und deinem friedlichen Himmel zu leben
das wünschen sich auch Alexander und
seine Frau er versucht das Dach ihrer
temporären Bleibe zu reparieren so gut
es irgendwie geht
niemand hat auf uns gewartet
wir können uns nur auf uns selbst
verlassen
wir sammeln Holz hier und dort
so in der Art
sie wünschen sich nichts mehr als dass
ihr altes Leben zurückkehren würde
Kinder haben hier Krach gemacht davon
hatten wir manchmal genug wenn sie im
Innenhof bei den Garagen etwas kaputt
gehauen haben und herumgeteilt sind ich
habe sie dann angeschrien ich habe
Kopfschmerzen
und Dinge kaputt schlagen hauptsache sie
sind am Leben
wenn du alles wieder so wäre wie es
einmal war so eine unheimliche Ruhe
mit der unheimlichen Ruhe nach dem
Angriff müssen sie irgendwie
zurechtkommen
[Musik]
allen voran Michael der den
Bombenangriff vor Ort überlebt hat
[Musik]
die Straße piramiskai wurde in der
Zwischenzeit von den ukrainischen
Behörden im Zuge der entkommunizierung
des Landes unbenannt in die Straße des
Gedenkens
trotz der Bedrohungslage in der
Ostukraine ist Michael nach Issum
zurückgekehrt
ja ich bin am 1 Dezember hierher
zurückgekehrt zuvor war ich in der
Region scherkassi als binnenflüchtling
dort gibt es sehr viele
Binnenflüchtlinge das Zuhause ist das
Zuhause und die Fremde ist die fremdung
arbeitet Michael in einem Kindergarten
als Wachmann
so dass mich der Direktor des
Kindergartens anrief und sagte dass
jemanden suchen
der bei Ihnen als Wachmann arbeiten
würde ich bin innerhalb von zwei Tagen
hergefahren meine verstorbene Tochter
hat hier eine Wohnung hinterlassen dort
wohne ich jetzt dort gibt es Licht
Wasser und Gas
für Michael ist die Arbeit im
Kindergarten in erster Linie Ablenkung
nach Ischium wollte ich zurück weil es
mal zu Hause ist die Arbeit ist eine
Sache wie soll ich ihnen das sagen ich
habe ihr einfach so lange gelebt ich bin
zwar nicht hier geboren aber ich habe 42
Jahre hier gelebt hier gibt es Arbeit
hier sind meine Freunde vieles ist hier
Michael möchte bleiben obwohl er beinahe
seine ganze Familie hier verloren hat
es ist kurz vor Weihnachten die Kinder
der Stadt bekommen humanitäre Hilfe für
ein paar unbeschwerte Momente für die
Kinder nach Monaten des Krieges packt
Michael an
er hilft beim ausladen und beim
koordinieren der Hilfsaktion
er selbst steht nur selten eine Minute
still
[Musik]
hat wieder eine Arbeit als Verkäuferin
aufgenommen wo sie mit ihren 71 Jahren
längst dem Pensionsalter wäre ihr bleibt
keine andere Wahl als in diesem zu
bleiben
wohin soll ich denn fahren
ich will nirgendwo hinfahren
zum Wegfahren braucht es eine Menge Geld
damit man ein gutes Leben hat
[Musik]
die ukrainischen Renten sind sehr
niedrig ich bekomme umgerechnet gerade
einmal 60 Franken im Monat
die einen verlassen isum die anderen
bleiben das Haus wird bald Geschichte
sein die Ruinen sollen abgerissen werden
ein Haus und seine Bewohner ein
Schicksal das mich nicht mehr losließ
eines unter Tausenden in der Ukraine
[Musik]